VEYSEL GUREN: Today
I'm going to tell you
about how we created a native
application using WordPress
REST API and Android Volley.
Nefisyemektarifleri.com
was in a search
of a professional mobile
technology company,
and they chose us regarding
our professional and innovative
works.
The challenge here
was that they were
using a highly-customized
WordPress package,
and creating a native app
would need web services
and networking system.
The challenge here was
that Nefis Yemek Tarifleri
website was deployed
on WordPress,
and it was highly customized.
So WordPress does not
have a default web service
system for an Android app.
So we have used WordPress
REST API and Android Volley
for creating an Android app.
Actually, WordPress doesn't
have a default web service
system for REST API.
So we have enabled WordPress
API for enabling REST services.
Actually, REST API is just
serving data with JSON,
and we are getting this data
and interpreting as objects.
This plug-in provides
an easy-to-use REST API
available via HTTP.
Correct your site's data
in simple JSON format,
including users, posts,
taxonomies, and more.
Retrieving or updating data is
as simple as sending an HTTP
request.
We used WP API as the
web service technology
for sending requests
to websites and getting
responses in JSON format.
Android Volley is
an HTTP library
that makes networking
easier and faster.
Volley is available through
the open AOSP repository.
Volley offers benefits
including automatic scheduling
of network requests, multiple
concurrent network connections,
transparent disk and memory
response caching, and support
for request superiority.
We used Volley for
enabling networking.
Web service responses coming
as JSON is parsed using JSON
and becomes ready for being
used as objects within coding.
It is easy to embed Volley, and
it supplies high performance.
In conclusion, we have developed
a native Android app that
is used by one million people.
And everyday, lots of people
are checking what and how
to cook from this Android app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]